الان مع اللواء فايز دويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي دكتور فايز مرحبا بك معنا
اذا ما الذي تقراه في الخطوه الاخيره
ساعات الماضيه شهدت وصول الصواريخ الى
مناطق لم تصلها من قبل على الاقل في هذه
الجوله نتحدث عن محيط القدس ومستوطنات بيت
لحم
يعني اولا هو ارسال رساله وهي
محاوله رشاء مجازا اقول الردع مقابل الردع
وبالتالي بان
الفصائل المقاومه الجهاد الاسلامي وهي
المشتركه فعليا في اطلاق الصواريخ انها
حتى لوحدها قادره على ان تفرض معادله لا
اقول فيها توازن الرعب ولكن الردع مقابل
الرضع وبالتالي توسيع الدائره جاء بعد
وقفه لعده ساعات كان الكل يتوقع انه هناك
امكانيه لايجاد ارضيه مشتركه للوصول الى
اتفاق رغم الرفض الاسرائيلي بايقاف عمليات
الاغتيال رغم انه اشار قد يتوقف بعد وقف
اطلاق النار وهذا هذا الخلاف او هذه
المساحه الرماديه اجهضت المقاربه وبالتالي
كان لزاما على الجهاد ان تطلق صواريخ ولكن
بمقاربه قد اسميها مجازا التصعيد المتدرج
ما الذي جرى في كثير من الحالات صاروخ
واحد قد يقلب المعادله سقوط الصاروخ في
جنوب تل ابيب ايقاع قتيل 13 جريح هنا حشره
نتنياهو بالزاويه وبالتالي هو الذي كان
يعتبر ان هذه العمليه عمليه محدوده زمانا
مكانا وحتى في اطار التنظيمات حماس القوه
الرئيسيه المسؤولي سياسيا اقتصاديا هي
خارج اللعبه الميدانيه هي في اطار التنسيق
فبالتالي انا استطيع ان
انفذ الاهداف التي صممت اصلا العمليه لها
ونجحت في اول جوله بحيث تم
استشهاد ثلاثه من قاده الجهاد الاسلامي
وبالتالي حققنا جزء كبير من اهدافنا لكن
جاء الصاروخ الذي سقطت بجنوب حيفا قلب
المعادله فكان لابد لذتنياهو امام شعبه ان
ان يصعد هذا التصعيد قبل بتصعيد اخر سواء
في اطراف القدس في اطراف بيت لحم اذا
دخلنا الان في مرحله التصعيد المتدرج
ولكنه المنضبط يعني ليس تصعيدا
مفتوحا لماذا
لان نتنياهو لا يرغب بجر حماس او اجبار
حماس او حشر حماس بالزاويه بحيث تتحول من
الغرفه المشتركه الى وحده الساحات والى
الدخول في الحرب وحماس كذلك كمن يسير في
حق الالغام لا ترغب بترك الجهاد منفرده
ولا ترغب بتوسيع دائره الصراع بانها تتحمل
البعد الامني والسياسي والاقتصادي
فبالتالي في ظل هذه التحديدات
القاتل الضيقه يتحرك لتناهو تتحرك حماس
يتحرك الجهاد ولكن اخرى بالتركيز تحدثنا
طويلا عن اتساع رقعه القصف والمدى الجديد
لكن ماذا عن المنظومه التي تستخدمها
اسرائيل مقلع داود والقبه الحديديه يعني
هل لديك فكره ما الذي يجري معها
يا سيدي يعني القبه الحديديه في معركه سيف
القدس تم الكثير من الحديث والجدال وكان
جدالا حادا جدا ما بين متطرفين لمصلحه
القبه تحدثوا عن 95% وما بين متطرفين ضد
القبه واعتبروها مشروعا فاشلا ومشروعا
تسويقيا بعض مراكز الدراسات في اسرائيل
اعطتها 5% ومنها من اعطاها 10% ومنها من
اعطاها 15% وانا كمتابع من خلال الاعداد
في معركه القدس اعطيت نسبه ما بين 65 الى
70% هذه درجه النجاح وبالتالي فيها
اخفاقات الان
ظهر امران جديدان الامر الاول وهم
متقاربين الخلل الفني الذي افشل المنظمه
الان ما هو البديل
والتعزيز هنا ياتي تعزيزا في الارتفاع
النسبي للصواريخ والمدى الصواريخ لماذا
القبه الحديديه تتعامل من خمسه كيلو متر
الى 70 75 كيلو متر مديات الصواريخ التي
تتعامل معها القبه الحديديه بينما بقلاع
داود يتعامل مع الصواريخ من 75 كيلو متر
الى ثلاث مئه كيلو متر الان بعض الصواريخ
التي اطلقت مداها 80 كيلو متر هي بالحقيقه
بداها يصل الى 120 كيلو متر على سبيل
المثال صاروخ براق 120 هنا اتحدث عن
صواريخ الجهاد الاسلامي وليس حماس ان
عندها صواريخ جراند 40 كيلومتر فجر وبدر
ثلاثه وبوراك 120 يصل مداهم فحد الاقصى
الى 120 كيلو متر اذا هنا كان لزاما من
وجهه نظر عسك ريه ان يتم اشراك القبه
الحديديه علما كلا كلا المنظومتين يعملان
على نفس الاسس الفيزيائيه والتطبيقيه
وشبكه الرادار هي شبكه موحده يعني شبك
منظومه الرادار للقبه الحديديه هي نفس
منظومه الرادار لمقلاع
دكتور الامر الاول الخلل الفني ويتم
معالجته كما شرحت بالتعزيز ما هو الامر
الاخر
يا سيدي الامر الاخر وهو الان عندك هناك
ثغره معينه هذه الثغره تاتي بعد الخمسه
وسبعين كيلو متر فكان لابد من تطبيقها
الامر الاخر ان هذه هذه المنظومه لم تجرب
سابقا وهذا هو الاختبار الاول فهي فرصه
لاسرائيل ان تقوم باختبارها كما قامت في
الحربين السابقتين باختبار القبه الحديديه
القبه الحديديه في عام 2014 لم تكن القبه
الحديديه في عام 2021 حصل عليها تطوير
كبير مقلاع داود وحتى السهم الذي ياتي في
الطبقه الثالثه بعد مقلاع داود لم يتم
اختباره فعليا تم اختباره في ميدان
التجارب طيب هذا فهم متعلق بمدى الصواريخ
بالقبه الحديديه ومقلاع داوود الان ماذا
بخصوص التكتيك المتبع من الغرفه المشتركه
وهي صرحت قبل قليل انها تتبع تكتيكا جديدا
قد يقلب نتائج هذه المعركه يعتمد على
تكتيك الاستنزاف
يا سيدي حتى هذه اللحظه ما يتم اجراءه من
تطبيقات في استخدام الصواريخ هو تقريبا
يعكس الصوره الحقيقيه في نهايه الحرب
السابقه
عندما تم استخدام مقاربات متعدده الان يتم
اطلاق انواع متعدده من الصواريخ بارتفاعات
مختلفه بمدايات مختلفه بزوايا اطلاق
مختلفه بكثافه مختلفه اذا لاحظ هناك اكثر
من عامل معايره استخدمته وهذا لم ياتي
وليد الصدفه ولكنه نتيجه التجارب السابقه
في الحرب السابقه اسوار القدس اي بمعنى
اخر يتم اطلاق مجموعه من الصواريخ وكنا
نشاهد الان في لحظات اطلاق الصواريخ نلاحظ
المحرق او نقطه السمك النقطه الاعلى التي
يصل اليها الصاروخ نجد ان في رشقا الواحده
مسافات بينيه ما بين الدخان الذي يخرج من
الصاروخ اي بمعنى اخر ان الصواريخ تطلق بي
زوايا ارتفاع مختلفه بزوايا جانبيه مختلفه
بكثافه مختلفه هذه هذه الامور هي التي
تربق القبه الحديديه ومقلاع داود ولكن حتى
هذه اللحظه لا تزال رغم الاعداد الكبيره
لاطلاق الصواريخ شارفت على الالف لا تزال
منضبطه ولا يوجد افراط في استخدام
الصواريخ لماذا قد تطول هذه الحرب
وبالتالي لا بد من
التدرج الشافي من التاخير الغرفه المشتركه
ايضا تصرح انها نجحت في منع الاستفراد كما
وصفته بحركه الجهاد الاسلامي او او
السرايا القدس الجناح العسكري ما الذي
تضيفه
باقي الفصائل داخل الغرفه المشتركه لتحقيق
ذلك اي منع الاستفراد القدس
يا سيدي الان الغرفه المشتركه بدات من عام
2006 وتدرجه وتم ايجاد مكتب تنفيذي لها
وبالتالي يشمل اكثر من فصيل نعم القاسم
المشترك هو
كتائب عز الدين القسام والشهداء القدس
ولكن هناك مجموعه حتى
تابعه لفتح والجبهه الشعبيه الديمقراطيه
جميعهم موجودين داخل الغرفه المشتركه الان
يتم قراءه المشهد ويتم
طبعا هذا الكلام انا انا انظر من بعد
تحليلي لديهم قوائم بموجوداتهم لديهم
قوائم بالقدرات لديهم بنك اهداف هل الجهات
الاسلامي لا يزال قادر على تنفيذ العمليات
بمفرده هل هو بحاجه الى دعم حتى هذه
اللحظه لا يزال الجهاد الاسلامي قادر على
ان ياخذ المعركه ولكن التخطيط مشترك
وحماس حتى هذه اللحظه وهنا
بعد تحليلي لا ترغب في توسيع دائره
الاشتباكات حتى لا يتم فرض ضغوطات على
المجتمع في غزه من عمان خبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه اللواء فايز دويري شكرا
جزيلا لك